start of the movie we are introduced to
a shady looking guy named Ciro who is
going through his neighborhood in Buenos
Aires along the way he spots a good
looking car and breaks into it it is
revealed that Ciro is a thug by
profession so he covertly removes the
stereo and steals a pair of sunglasses
present in the overhead compartment
right then he has a sudden urge to
urinate but instead of going out and
doing it like a gentleman he urinates
all over the rear seat he even farts
several times to make sure the car's
owner's day is ruined but after Ciro
finishes up and prepares to leave the
door doesn't open scared he tries
opening the other doors but all of them
are shut intact slowly but steadily
Panic sets in as Ciro realizes that he
is in big trouble he desperately tries
breaking the window glass but all of
them appear to be impenetrable Ciro then
dismantles a part of the door and tries
to open it from the inside however in
the process he hurts his hand badly
causing it to bleed when nothing works
Ciro pulls out his gun and shoots at the
front window but the bullet ricochets
off and penetrates his thigh this makes
him scream in pain and to avoid
excessive loss of blood he removes his
shirt and wraps it around the wound
after a while a lady suddenly arrives
outside and begins applying lipstick
looking at the window Ciro tries to seek
her assistance but it appears that the
woman is oblivious to Sarah's presence
inside he shouts at her but she ignores
him and walks away Ciro then tries to
contact his wife but the phone's battery
expires before the call can be completed
after several hours of failed attempts a
tired Ciro falls asleep the most
satisfying part of all of this is that
he Dutch ovened himself the next morning
Ciro awakens feeling incredibly parched
and realizes he's out of water in a
state of desperation he resorts to
licking the fog off the window to quench
his thirst fog doesn't have water you
dummy as the day progresses he takes out
his backpack and removes the car stereo
to listen to some music hoping to
distract himself from his dire situation
as one of his favorite songs begins
playing on the radio zero becomes
completely engrossed in its Rhythm and
lyrics momentarily forgetting his
troubles ironically his situation is
described in the song which mentions
hazy Windows blood and being trapped so
right after the song ends a motivated
Siro tries unlocking the door once more
suddenly a phone begins to ring in the
car's stereo and when Siro picks it up a
man answers from the other end he
welcomes Ciro into the car and
introduces himself as Dr Enrique Ferrari
Enrique goes on to say that he owns the
SUV and has been robbed 28 times in his
life Ciro is actually the 29th guy who
has attempted to steal from him hearing
this an enraged zero desperately demands
to be let free but Enrique makes it
clear that he's in no position to make
demands after this he starts explaining
his vehicle's features he calls it 4x4
because it has a security alarm system
linked to his phone that allows him to
lock all of the four cars doors it is
soundproof as well as bulletproof
because of independent suspension it
can't be moved from the inside
furthermore all of the glass is
polarized even the front windshield the
gas tank which can hold up to 120 liters
of fuel is the only thing that isn't
indestructible Enrique caution Sierra
that a full gas tank is a potential bomb
and that if he does something foolish
the car will blast with him inside he
then opens up to Ciro revealing that he
is a 60 year old widower from kilms and
reminisces about his idyllic childhood
in a middle-class family where doors
were never locked he laments that his
current life is a far cry from his
innocent past and Longs for those
simpler times to test Ciro's moral
compass Enrique asks him what he would
do if he caught his own son stealing it
but Ciro has had enough and threatens to
report Enrique to the authorities in a
moment of madness he even brazily
suggests that he could kill Enrique and
his entire family if he were to be set
free good strategy good strategy
unfortunately as he is ranting the phone
suddenly disconnects further inflaming
Ciro's anger and frustration after a
while Enrique case switches on the air
conditioner and sets it to the loudest
setting to torment the Intruder Ciro
tries his best to turn it off but it
seems that nothing inside the car Works
he has no choice but to remove his shirt
from his wound and put it back on to
stop the bleeding in his knee he tears a
piece of his pants off and wraps that
over the wound and shearly lies in a
fragile state Enrique calls him again
and asks him the same question what
would he do if he found his kid stealing
Enrique also promises that he would give
him water if he answers the question
correctly hearing the reward thirsty
Siro responds to the question but
Enrique remains unsatisfied with his
answer Ciro begs him to stop claiming
that he has learned his lesson but
Enrique seems unconcerned and continues
telling him about another event last
year two guys broke into his daughter's
residence while she was parking her car
despite being well prepared for such
situations the thieves held Enrique's
grandson hostage for three hours
meanwhile Ciro is uninterested in
Enrique's tales and asks him what type
of doctor would keep a wounded person
deprived of water before hanging up and
recap a compliments him on his query and
challenges him to guess what sort of a
doctor he is as zero Ponders over his
options a police vehicle approaches and
pulls up alongside the SUV he is in
seeing this Ciro is filled with optimism
and tries his best to grab the officer's
attention however the officer instead
issues a ticket to the SUV and walks
away ah the only thing police can be
relied on for hours pass and Enrique
finally contacts Ciro again demanding
his full name and ID number before he
will give him any water Ciro reluctantly
complies and Enrique instructs him to
find the washing hose at the back of the
car where he can access some water
despite the water being a bright blue
color Ciro is too desperate to care and
drinks it down frantically his parched
throat grateful for any liquid even
windshield wiper fluid or whatever the
hell that was in the next scene a hungry
Ciro is nearly compelled to consume a
lone bug that has found its way inside
the car Ciro is suffering from fever as
the wound in his leg is turning yellow
when Enrique learns of this he switches
on the air conditioner to calm the
Intruder down then he reveals that he is
also suffering Enrique is dying of
cancer and has been given a year to live
by his Physicians however Ciro is too
weak to listen and after a few minutes
he passes out due to exhaustion and
fever after he wakes up Ciro again gets
the Vigor to escape he haphazardly
searches the car handbook looking for a
way out but all he manages to do is chew
a page out of desperation he becomes so
helpless that he pisses in a container
and drinks it a little pissed by
suddenly a thief attempts to break into
the SUV this gives Cyril renewed hope of
getting out and he gets excited however
the excitement quickly turns into
disappointments when the robber is
apprehended and beaten up by the locals
as the night descends Ciro's thirst and
hunger intensify causing him to become
Delirious he starts pondering about the
unequal distribution of resources in the
world where a small fraction of
individuals possess an abundance of
wealth While others are left to struggle
Cyril expresses his frustration with the
systems and laws that favor the wealthy
perpetuating the cycle of poverty for
the rest despite the dire situation he
is in he proclaims that he will not
submit to the system even if it means
getting shot this is the reason why he
chose becoming a thief just like his
father and grandfather the next day
Enrique calls again and this time he
reads the newspaper to Siro he says he's
in a good mood and leads Ciro to a
hidden chocolate bar in the SUV after
spending the whole day doing nothing
zero suddenly comes to life he strikes
one of the doors he damaged earlier and
eventually succeeds in making a tiny
hole that exposes him to the outside he
cries through the little hole in an
attempt to get someone's attention but
fails later Enrique phones again to say
that he has contacted Sierra's family
the latter weeps when he hears his
family's names and begs Enrique not to
hurt them with tears in his eyes he asks
what he has done to deserve this
punishment but Enrique is unmoved by all
this instead he takes itsyro's criminal
record and reveals that he had
previously killed someone it turns out
several years ago Ciro stormed into a
residence to commit theft but he was
stopped by a couple of Brothers with no
way out he shot them mercilessly Enrique
also mentions an elderly bus driver that
Ciro had severely beaten Ciro however
refuses to accept responsibility blaming
the driver for not allowing him to loot
the passengers after charging his phone
using solar power Ciro attempts to
contact his wife but to no avail so he
leaves a voicemail pouring out his heart
and apologizing for his past mistakes
following this he continuously presses
the car's start button and manages to
switch it on it's revealed that it can
also be activated without a key after
pressing at a certain amount of times
like a pattern Siro then fastens a
seatbelt and shifts the gear into
reverse the gear however becomes Locked
In Reverse forcing him to drive backward
to grab people's attention he speeds up
the automobile and crashes it into a
post fortunately the airbag deploys in a
timely manner and he is unharmed Ciro is
ultimately able to escape by kicking
down the weakened back glass he is in
excruciating pain yet he somehow manages
to drag himself to a local gas station
restaurant to get some food as he Savers
each mouthful of his meal the restaurant
manager urges him to pay for it and exit
right away angered by the rude Behavior
Ciro pulls out his gun and shoots the
manager the very next second Sierra
drifts back to reality revealing that he
was daydreaming oh and that he is still
trapped in the SUV his phone rings again
and it's Enrique on the other end in A
desperate plea Sierra threatens to
commit the unthinkable but Enrique
remains unfazed by his words he laughs
maniacally and arrives in front of the
car finally revealing his face Enrique
then gets in the vehicle and starts
tending to Ciro's injuries the latter is
so exhausted that he lacks the energy to
free and ultimately falls asleep but
when he gets up he musters up all his
courage picks up his gun and shoots at
Enrique Ciro barely misses but he does
manage to LEAP out of the car finally
setting himself free after days of
excruciating captivity as he drags
himself on the floor firing shots into
the air Enrique desperately tries to get
him back he is almost successful but
just then a police officer notices the
commotion and orders Enrique to put down
his gun when the cunning doctor refuses
an intense Showdown begins cut to two
hours later a large number of people
media personnel and cops have gathered
around the scene Enrique is still
holding zero at gunpoint despite
everyone pleading with him to give up
when nothing works an experience to
negotiator is summoned he immediately
gets to work and asks Enrique what he
wants as the entire country watches the
doctor begins to list the daily
struggles he faces that the government
fails to address he explains how he has
to dodge over 2 000 piles of dog
excrement on the street while walking to
work because pet owners do not clean up
after their dogs he is also fed up with
the drains that have not been cleaned up
the garbage that has been littered on
the roads and the terrible state of the
homeless people not to mention the
deforestation problem hearing all this
the public connects with Enrique and
starts supporting him however The
Negotiator does not give up and
ultimately convinces Enrique to let go
of the boy after Ciro is apprehended by
the cops Enrique is asked to surrender
but he doesn't just the opposite Enrique
gets into his car and sets off the timer
resulting in a deadly explosion he is
killed on the spot but thankfully none
of the people nearby are injured the
movie ends asiro is dragged away to the
hospital while the general public is
left to ponder if the cold-hearted
doctor was the good guy after all that
fog not having water thing was a troll
by the way I just wanted to see how many
people would comment about it before
finishing the video
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching